But coming back to my question, I think.
Well, we're all familiar with what a binary trees no matter what is purposes. But
how do we implement this?
With which one of those four destructors would implement this?
Actually, the dictionary is the right answer because with the two pull.
You have two limitations number one the keys
are indexed.
Number two, you cannot restructure it.
He said the Tuple is
immutable
let's start sets. Don't even allow you to
have keys and let's are like tuples they
are indexed which brings us to dictionaries.
So let me show you how you can Implement a
binary tree with a dictionary
So let's say we have a binary tree.
Okay, what are the values?
1 2 3
Five and six, let's do that one exactly.
So we have one two, three five and
six.
What is the root note the root note is one?
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to put my first node in here.
So I will say node.
with value 1
but this node branches off to two other nodes.
And it has a left child and a right child.
So it's left child.
And it's right child.
It's left child is what?
two
Right, but we can just say
two or three here because well.
It's children.
are also
dictionaries
so we have to open up another pair of curly brackets
for both the left and right child.
It's left child will be just like its parent.
I just want to be I want to indent this so it's
clear what's going on in here. The left child will also have
a node.
Element it's value will be two.
And it's left child. Well, let's come back to the children in a moment.
But every node will have a left child.
Or it may they may have a left chart in
a right child.
Okay.
And for the right child, I'm just going to copy this bit.
The node will be three.
Okay.
Now what children do to do two
and three have two has two children five and
six so it's left child.
Let me do three first because this is okay three has no
children. So this will be none.
And it's right child will be done.
Okay, so it's a leaf in other words.
but the left child
will have two more nodes.
Okay.
I can I'm gonna expand this.
It's node will be 5.
left child
Does it have any children?
It has no children, so this will be none.
And it has no right children.
No, right child, so this would be not.
oops
Sorry about that.
Right child will be.
and same thing for
the right child of number two
The right child has no is annuit value
6.
now if you look at this, it's kind of
we're building right? I mean it's a lot of
A lot a lot going on in here.
but
we could do it.
Now you're actually implemented this way. This is not a practical way
to implement.
Binary ideally, what you would do is you would
create a class.
And Abstract away the process of adding a
child.
Or removing a child or searching for a child.
Okay, so why you can't do this? Obviously, I
mean, this is a tiny binary tree by look up look at
the size of this thing. It's hideous.
We will look at how we can how we would create a binary tree
class.
Add methods for adding child searching for
child rebalancing the tree all that good stuff.
Okay, but let me collapse this.
Can you tell me how we can access?
six
What do I need to type here online 218 to access?
the value 6 in this binary tree
Let me let's at least start with the first one. How do we access the
root node?
How do we access the root node?
Okay.
I just showed you how to get to the node root node.
Okay, so we can get one. But now how do I get to the
Sixth the number six. So what I
need to do is first go left.
Then go right.
So I need to go to the left node. And
then from there go to the right notes. I will type in here instead of
binary tree. No, I would say left.
child
and if I want to confirm I can type in node.
This will give you number two.
but if I want to go to number six
after I go to Left child, I have to visit the right child.
And then I will type a note.
There we have it.
So later on especially in module 3 when we
are going to build binary trees.
And we'll look at other graph data structures.
This is what our data structure will look like now.
Like I said, we won't do it this way. This is a this is
a very bad way. You can just see even with the small example. I
ran into errors rather. We will create classes like
class binary tree and then
we will have methods for adding removing searching
Etc.